- Hi, everyone.
Sal here from Khan Academy.
Welcome to our Homeroom live stream,
very excited about the
conversation we're gonna have
with Linda Darling-Hammond.
Before we jump into that,
I'll give my standard announcements.
First, a reminder that Khan Academy
is a not-for-profit organization.
We can only exist and do the work we do
because of philanthropic donations
from folks like yourself.
So if you believe in a
free world class education
for anyone anywhere, which I hope you do,
please think about going
to khanacademy.org/donate.
I also wanna give a special shout out
to several organizations that stepped up,
especially as COVID was hitting.
We were already running
at a deficit before COVID
and as you can imagine,
our server costs have
gone up dramatically.
We're trying to accelerate
a whole series of programs
and various efforts and
so our deficits only grew,
and to help us close some of that,
a special thanks Bank of
America, Google.org, AT&T,
Fastly, Novartis, and actually
the Amgen foundation as well,
and many other supporters,
foundations, corporations
that have helped Khan
Academy get to the point
that we could be of
service during this crisis.
Now with that, I'm really excited
to introduce our guest
Linda Darling-Hammond,
who I would describe on many dimensions.
Stanford professor, hopefully
she considers me a friend,
president of the California
State Board of Education
and the founding president of
the Learning Policy Institute.
So Linda, thanks for joining us.
- Happy to be here.
- So maybe our first question.
I encourage anyone who's watching,
if you have questions for Linda
who's an expert really in all
things, education and beyond,
put your questions on the message board
on Facebook and YouTube
and we have team members
who will help surface it
to Linda and myself.
But maybe our starting point is
given the crisis that we're in around
the COVID, distance learning,
where do you think we are in this journey?
How are you thinking about it?
What do you think are the most
pressing issues right now?
- Well, there's several issues.
I mean, one is obviously
because we are in distance learning,
doing that as well as
we can possibly do it.
And that means, of course,
closing the digital divide,
we're working hard on that in California.
It means being sure that teachers
have the training to use the
tools and materials well,
synchronous and asynchronous
instruction in the right ways.
It also means social and
emotional wraparound supports.
Kids are going through a lot of trauma
in many, many communities
and the experience that kids
are having is very disparate.
Some kids are home with
parents who can work at home.
Others are having to be home
while their parents are at work.
Some have parents unemployed,
there are health crises in
a number of communities.
So whatever we're doing
on distance learning
has to have a social and
emotional support component to it,
figuring out what kids need,
making sure that the school
resources to support those needs
are also available, counseling
and other kinds of resources,
and then getting solid
distance learning mounted.
And it's happening in
some very creative ways
in some districts across the country
and certainly in California.
- And what would you say,
given that I completely agree,
because there's been so
much conversation about
do schools open or do they go
to distance learning or not
that it feels like there's
been a little bit of a gap
and clear guidance on what good
or even adequate distance
learning looks like,
do you have examples of
places that are doing it well
that could be emulated by other places
or just general guidelines?
We've actually been
trying to do it on our own
so it's good for us to sync up on this.
- Yeah, well the California
Department of Education
just released some guidance
this week on distance learning
that does sort of summarize
what some of the research shows,
matters in distance learning.
And then there are
districts across the state
that are doing really exciting work.
Among the things that matter are
having everyone sort of
on a common platform,
training parents as well as
students as well as teachers
in how to access the materials and so on,
having interactive
instruction synchronously,
it's not like just the stage on the stage.
It's being sure that the things
that are being communicated
can be discussed among
kids in breakout rooms
and in chats and so on
being sure that interactive
element is there,
having good materials for
asynchronous instruction.
And you're of course familiar
with Khan Academy materials
that a lot of districts are
using and there are others
across content areas that
when those themselves
are well scaffolded,
where we've done the right
kind of assessment to tell kids
where to tune in on the things
that they need to work on
and then bring it back
in line with the teacher
and the peers for further discussion.
You can get very substantial
gains in learning
if you've got all of
those components in place.
And that's what we're trying
to make sure is happening.
Long Beach is a place in California
that's doing really
interesting work around this,
San Diego many others.
I will say in Long Beach
one of the things I love
and they are actually,
it happens using some kind of materials
but they're having teachers teach in ways,
and this is similar to your
approach to reaching everyone,
the great teachers
who are really good on certain topic areas
are giving courses and
lessons anyone can tune into.
So sometimes thousands of
kids tune in to teachers
who are teaching particular things,
other teachers can tune in
and learn the strategies
that that teacher is using
and then they can use the materials
that are available for practice
and for the next stages.
So there are ways that the technology
can really leverage great
teaching and materials
that we couldn't do when we
were just in single classrooms,
that we need to learn how to
take advantage of right now.
- That's super valuable (mumbles)
this is a school district
that we've been working very closely with
at Khan Academy for many
years and they have a recently
retiring superintendent,
Chris Steinhauser,
but the whole team there
they've really been always
one of the most innovative
school districts.
And actually that project,
that's actually a little skunkworks
that are at least aspects
of what you described
is that I've been working on with them.
Well maybe there's multiple projects,
but yeah we're doing that exactly
so that some of their top
teachers in the district
can set up group sessions
that any kid in the district
can attend.
So you're no longer tied
to your specific zip code
or neighborhood anymore.
- And they've had some where
2000 kids have shown up.
'Cause teachers can be
famous just like movie stars
for the amazing work that they do.
And people can get that experience.
I think this is all about
inventing and sharing.
That's what this moment
in history is about,
human beings invent, that's what we do,
we inquire and we invent
and then we've got to share
what we're learning.
- And just to double click on that,
everything you said makes
all the sense in the world
and it's very much aligned
with a lot of what we've
been talking about as well.
But if I'm a teacher I'm used to doing,
let's say five days a week, an hour a day,
maybe I spend some time grading
papers, et cetera at home
and lesson planning,
how does it I think the guidance around
making the video conferencing
sessions more interactive,
but does it become
five, one hour video
conference sessions a week,
what would you recommend that teacher do?
Do they do fewer shorter ones?
Should they do smaller groups?
Or it's really, should
they just experiment
and see what works?
- Well, it does depend on
the age level of the kids
as well as what the kids have had before
so it's a really challenging thing
and I just wanna say this, if
you're teaching little kids
and you're trying to do it
online, that's very challenging
'cause they're squirrely and so on,
but that's where you need
a lot more interactive
kind of materials, very short sessions,
interspersed with some physical activity,
you're doing some PE in
the middle of the time
that you're working,
you may have low budget
art, kinds of things
that everybody can engage in
if you're working with
smaller kids, for example,
in the middle of instruction
where you're also reading to them.
But generally speaking modest
amounts of direct instruction,
short amounts of that
with lots of opportunities
for interactions.
The Zoom breakout room
is a wonderful thing
and when kids get old enough
and have been taught
how to work in groups,
you can pose some information,
you can pose the problem,
you can pose the question,
send them off to work on it
and talk about it for a while,
have them come back and
share their solutions
if it's in a math or science
context or their ideas,
their decisions in a debate context,
you can have them engaged
in debates and projects.
Some of the asynchronous time
can also be done collectively
because a lot of education is
doing things both individually
and then talking about it with others
and teaching kids how to
manage their own learning.
This is an opportunity for us to help kids
take agency in learning
and to really teach them
how to set up their own sort
of learning management systems,
how to use the materials
that they're gonna use
asynchronously well,
so that they're learning how to learn
because that's the critical
skill for 21st century society,
is being a self managing learner.
This is the time to get away
from transmission teaching
which is I'm talking and
you're just writing it down
and spitting it back on a test
towards teaching kids to
be increasingly engaged
in self-managing in their learning.
And we've seen that the schools
that are project based schools,
where kids are engaged in
doing projects individually
and collectively have
had hardly missed a beat
in the switch to online
because the kids were
already learning how to plan
and manage parts of their learning.
They were devoted to their projects
'cause they cared about them,
they were preparing their presentations.
They could present them.
Part of the homework sometimes
is go present it to your grandparents,
I love that kind of homework
'cause I'm a grandmother
and you want your kids to
have audiences for their work.
And so they present in a variety of ways,
but then the formal presentations
at the end of the year
often, to a broader audience.
In one case in Oakland,
the kids have been working on
a safety plan for their school
because it was a very
dangerous school to get to.
Their last end of the year presentation
was to the city council
who actually took up some new policies
to make it safer for
kids to get to school.
So when they do go live,
they'll have a new path to get there.
So I think that's part of it,
keeping kids engaged in ways
that they really care about
and helping them learn
to be more and more able
to manage their own learning.
- And what's interesting about everything
you just mentioned is those
sound like best practices,
even if we were doing in-person learning,
make the students interact
as much as possible,
have them take agency, have
them apply what they're doing,
maybe have an audience to see
the artifacts of the work.
What are your biggest fears
about the situation
that we're in right now?
And do you see some silver linings?
Maybe one of them is that
some of these practices
become more mainstream.
- Well, of course there are fears.
I mean, we have a huge
equity gap in this country.
I mean, we fund schools inequitably,
we have a huge income gap,
the communities that are
being affected by COVID
in the black and brown communities
that have been hit employment
wise and health wise
and in a variety of ways,
those are huge huge problems
that we confront all the time
and they are exacerbated right now.
So the other piece of what's
needed, and we saw this too.
The schools that were community schools
that had social workers and
wrap around health and mental
health services already
engaged in school
were able to meet the
needs of the families
in a much better way.
We got to do that,
a lot of districts are doing
one on one even distanced,
socially distanced home
visits, where that's needed
as well as one-on-one on
the phone and on the Zoom.
And in other ways to connect with families
and ensure that kids are
getting what they need.
We're gonna need distance learning hubs
and San Francisco's putting
up distance learning hubs
for 6,000 kids where
they can come to a place
where they can get food
and they can get equipment
and they can be online and
they can also have counselors
and social workers and
others to be available
to be sure that their whole
child needs are being met.
So that's the biggest
fear is that we won't
step up and be sure that kids are
surrounded with all of
the care that they need.
But it is happening and
I'm just very inspired
by the way that educators
and others are stepping up.
The silver linings are very interesting
because if you go back to
the beginning of March,
we had this digital divide
where about 30% of kids,
20 to 30% either didn't have connectivity
or devices that they could use at home.
In California,
we've probably closed
that divide by about half.
We have $5 billion going
out to schools right now
as part of the federal money,
as well as a lot of corporations of course
stepped up a lot of districts,
went into their reserves
and bought computers,
a lot of companies are
figuring out how to get
digital access in much
more reasonable ways.
We should and could have
closed the digital divide
by the end this year.
Well that wasn't gonna happen
unless we had that necessity.
We will have teachers and students
and other staff technologically proficient
in ways that would not have happened
unless we had to do that.
And if you think about
our economy in California
and I don't mean to leave
out the rest of the country,
this is true elsewhere also,
the technological
underpinnings of the economy
are growing at an exponential rate.
So the fact that we're gonna have
a technologically proficient populace
that cuts across lines of class and income
in ways that we didn't
previously is a huge gain,
we need to take advantage of it.
And people are learning
to teach in new ways
that we need to capture, understand, share
and take advantage of.
- That makes a ton of sense.
And we're getting a ton of
questions here on social media.
One question, and this is a question
that I have heard a little bit too
from Facebook Zahid Zia is asking,
it sounds like Zahid is a teacher,
I'm struggling on how to perform
quick formative assessment
in a virtual classroom.
For those of you all who
aren't used to the language,
formative assessment is
assessment as kids are learning
so that a teacher can understand
how well they've learned the material
and where they might need extra help.
And I'll extend that question,
a lot of the school districts last year
had to just go to pass
fail, cause they're like,
not everyone has equal access.
Even now I'm hearing a lot
of teachers are struggling
with Zahid's question
or how do I do assessments
in a world where
I can't proctor them?
And this is all happening at the same time
that things like standardized assessments
are getting difficult to administer.
So is there kind of an information gap
that's developing because of this crisis?
- You mean information
about how kids are doing...
- About how kids are doing
and what they've learned and have learned.
- There may be, I do think
that we can help teachers
with tools for formative
and diagnostic assessment.
One of the things we did in California,
it's on the CD website
is a guidance around
using diagnostic and
formative assessments.
And we've approved in the state
about probably a dozen different
formative and diagnostic
assessment tools and programs
that people can access.
Some districts are using them regularly
so that you can see where
kids are on a regular basis.
A lot of them are very short assessments.
The smarter balanced assessment system
has all kinds of formative
and interim assessment tools,
they are freely available
to every teacher,
public and private schools
and that you can burrow in on a topic area
to see where kids are kind of in a domain
as well as more broadly.
And so we want teachers
to get familiar with
how to use these tools.
They don't require proctoring,
they don't require some
special testing context.
They just require the time and the tools
right there for kids
and then you can guide your
instruction accordingly.
And they usually scale across the entire K
through eight or 12 scale of progress.
And then you can figure out
what materials you need to use.
The other thing, of course,
our formative assessments that
teachers would do themselves.
And it's a little harder, perhaps,
when you've got a video screen of kids
to check for understanding,
but you can use the chat box,
you can use exit tickets out the door
at the end of the class and
say answer this question,
tell me what you understood
or what you didn't understand
and begin to get those kinds
of tools directly in the mix
for the way in which the
learning takes place.
- And then how would you
handle assessment in terms of
even giving students grades
for maybe the K through eight crowd,
that's not as important.
The grades are a little
bit lower at stakes,
but obviously as you go into high school,
folks really start caring about grades,
especially as it shows
up on their transcripts,
it's being used for things
like college admissions,
how do should a teacher think about it,
authenticating students?
Should they just go to a real honor code?
Are there ways to ensure that
there isn't some shady behavior going on
while other people taking
the test or getting help,
things like that?
- Well, I do think that
we need to be thinking
in honor code terms in general
in the society and in life.
And one of my kids went to
college based on the fact that
they had an honor code,
because they wanted to
be really in a place that
was ethically organized around that idea.
The more we use authentic assessments,
the more kids have to sort of
produce and defend and explain
what they've done and show it,
the less you have to worry about cheating.
It's kind of like the
driver's test in the DMV.
You might be able to
figure out how to cheat
on the multiple choice test,
but you got to get in that car
and you've got to drive with the driver
and show that you can do
all of the things on the driver's test.
Now in New York, they
have a higher standard
because you have to parallel park
as well as everything else.
But it is authentic
and I think the more we work
with authentic assessments
of learning that kids present and defend,
the more you can see that
they've really learned it.
And I think that's the
direction we should be going.
It's the direction that the
advanced placement assessments,
the international baccalaureate
and others have been
going in for some years.
In terms of grades,
my view is that we should
always be honoring the learning.
And the goal is to see what you can get to
not privileged people
who've had more experience with something
who get there faster.
So I believe in approach
and this is very well
documented in the research,
that if you give people the
opportunity to get instruction,
try an authentic task, get
feedback often using rubrics
or other tools, try it again, revise it.
What should count is where
you end up in your learning,
as you've done this opportunity to engage,
practice and improve rather
than where you started.
And that makes it possible for kids
who started further behind
to show the progress
because they're getting
the opportunity to iterate.
If you think about anything we do in life
that is an actual performance,
it's through that process of trying,
getting feedback and trying again,
and the more we grade like that,
the more we actually drive
learning upwards for everyone
and the more we close the achievement gap.
- I couldn't agree with
you more and you know this,
but a lot of our resources at
Khan Academy were exactly that
make sure that kids get as much
practice, as much feedback,
that if they they're at an 80% state,
that's not the end of the world,
they can keep working on it
so that they can eventually
get to where they're going.
And also I 100% agree with the authentic,
I've been brainstorming
with some educators
and we might even make this part of
that schoolhouse.world project,
where if a student is
able to take an assessment
on Khan Academy, say of course
challenger or a unit test,
and they're taking a screen capture
while they're talking out
loud to show their reasoning,
and then they submit that video.
That's actually very hard to cheat that
and in a lot of ways, you're
gonna get a lot more texture
than you would have had even
with a traditional assessment.
So I think there's going
to be some models that...
- I love that and you're
gonna get more learning
because actually when
we explain what we know,
we're actually solidifying
it in our brains
in a way that makes it
more deeply understood
so I think that's the
way we should be going.
- 100%.
Well, one question for
you, this is from me,
I've always wondered, and
I don't know to what degree
you have jurisdiction over
things like the A to G standards.
That's probably more than
the University of California
Regents, but I am curious,
right now in California they
have the A to G standards.
Every state has kind of the,
you need this many years
of foreign language,
this many years of math,
this many years of English
in almost every state
and almost every country,
it's still described very
much in terms of time
not in terms of outcome.
And as you just described,
it's much more valuable to think of things
in terms of outcome. and some
kids might take a few months,
some kids might take a
few years to learn it,
but if they get to that
outcome, that's what matters.
Is there a movement?
'Cause I do think these
A to G type Carnegie unit type things
are actually one of the main blockers
to moving to more of
whatever you wanna call it,
outcome based or competency-based world.
- Well, there is a
competency based movement.
There's been one for 30 or 40 years.
You probably are aware that
there are always people
talking about this and trying to do it.
We've kind of been locked in concrete
around the system of education
that we've had for so long.
The courses that are in high school
that most people think about,
algebra, geometry, and trigonometry
were taken in that order, alphabetical,
biology, chemistry, physics,
in that order alphabetical,
they're in the A through G system,
those were all developed by
the committee of 10 and 1890.
It is time for a new approach.
I'm actually just now joining
an international committee
that OACD is forming
because I've been talking with
folks there for a long time
about we need to have a new committee
to think about what it really
means to have a curriculum
for the 21st century
which we're well into now,
but we haven't caught up
kind of in terms of our,
and this moment of disruption
in the education system
is causing people to
think, what really matters?
What should we really be doing here?
How do we do it?
What's really important in addition to
certain kinds of content
knowledge for sure,
is the habits of mind,
the way in which you can learn to learn,
more knowledge was created
between 1999 and 2003.
Then in the entire history
of the world proceeding,
knowledge is exponentially increasing.
Technology knowledge is doubling
probably faster than every
11 months at this point.
So people need some
understanding of the concepts
and structures and factual basis,
but they also need a
huge amount of capacity
to learn to learn.
And that's what we should be engendering
because kids are gonna
be working with knowledge
that hasn't been discovered yet
using technologies that
haven't been invented yet
to solve enormous problems in the world
that we have not managed to solve.
And our way of counting
progress in education
doesn't take these things
into account right now.
There are places, New
Hampshire is one of them
across the country
that's really trying to get
to a competency based system
and there are others
that are working on it,
but this is the moment to really be asking
and trying to answer those
questions in new ways.
- Yeah (mumbles) one more question,
there was a question from
Facebook Michelle Miralis Capriati
and I'll extend her question a little bit.
She says, how do we work to
retain teachers at this time?
I know you've done a lot
of research in this area.
There's a mass exodus
of educators right now
due to COVID related issues,
and few and fewer entering the field,
how much of this is on your
radar at the state board?
And yeah, what's the solution here?
- Well, we keep educators by valuing them
and by supporting them.
And so number one where
schools are open and childcare
and other aspects of the
systems, they need to be safe.
We actually do know a lot
about how to keep them safe.
We know the importance of face coverings,
physical distancing, testing and tracking,
keeping kids and teachers in small cohorts
and in the countries that
have kept schools open safely,
they've been very diligent
about those things
and where we are in environments
that your infection rates
have been brought down,
the curve has been been sufficiently,
we need to be sure that
teachers are supported
in all of those physical ways,
as well as in all of the
sort of intellectual ways
to do the work with kids in
ways that can be successful.
Same thing is true when
we're in distance learning,
is how to support that
work so that it's doable,
so people have opportunities to learn,
so that they're being supported
and they're being respected.
Of course, in teaching,
there are also always issues
of adequate training and pay
because we don't invest in this country
in the teaching profession in the way that
many other countries
do on a regular basis.
So all of those things
have to be on the table.
And again, I think we're at a moment
where parents are appreciating educators
in ways they didn't before perhaps
because they can see how
challenging the work is
with their one or two or maybe
three children in their house
however many they have
and can imagine what it
might be to do that with 30
or whatever the number is in a classroom.
So I hope we'll see a
redoubling of commitment
to the support of the teaching profession.
- Yeah, we couldn't agree more.
Well we're pretty close to
time, maybe in that last minute,
if any final thoughts,
and I am also curious,
how is the state board viewing this?
Are y'all viewing this
as a one year situation?
It could it be longer, folks I
know who know about epidemics
are saying we should at
least plan for longer.
Is that kind of part of the
conversation at the state level?
- Well, I think that
there is a recognition
that we may be in and out of
physical school right now.
The California government,
the Department of Public
Health, et cetera,
getting ready to issue guidance about
how small groups can come together safely
even when whole schools are
not able to be actualized
or in gear.
But we may have points in time
and we will in different counties,
where it is safe to go back to school.
But then there'll be kids
who need to be quarantined or something
and they'll have to be
on distance learning.
So we're gonna have to
have this flexibility
in the ways in which a
school is experienced
in the purpose of education,
even if the place of education changes.
And that's why it's so very important
to close the digital divide,
help everyone be actively
supported in that work
because it's going to be a
reality for quite a while.
And even when get a vaccine,
which people hope for within this year,
which will allow us I think to
get back to school in person,
we're gonna have fires
and floods and hurricanes
and other climate related
events that are going to make
the physical place of
schooling a changeable place.
And we will need to be
prepared for that to be
the way in which we understand
that people have to be prepared
to learn wherever they are
and that we have to support
that in a variety of ways.
- Now, great, super important message.
Well, Linda, thank you so much
and I look forward to
continuing this conversation.
Hopefully we get you
again on this live stream
and I actually have
a lot of stuff I would love
to keep talking to you about,
of how we could partner together
to help teachers and families
around not just California,
but the country.
Thank you so much, Linda
- Pleasure to be here, thanks.
- So thanks everyone again
for joining this live stream.
Hopefully you found this conversation
as interesting as I did.
I always comment about
how fast the time goes.
There's a many questions my apologies,
that I wasn't able to get to.
I will make an announcement.
We have another leader in
education next Tuesday, John King,
former US Secretary of Education,
is going to be joining us.
And as you can imagine,
we're gonna be talking about
a lot of the the same issues
about how do we do
distance learning right?
What are gonna be the implications?
Are there going to be some silver linings?
How do we navigate all of this together?
So I look forward for y'all
to join me on Tuesday.
So with that stay safe
and I will see you in
the future live stream.